this place probably had a family Shh
with feeling stop here's the thing I
come from a Chinese background we
literally try to eat every bit of the
animal so I'm pretty used to this I
wonder how many boogers are in this
burrito
it looks crazy it looks like regular
meats what kind of meat you be eaten mmm
do you think at all though you can see
like the hairs it's a little hairy
that's like when I hadn't shaved for two
weeks it's a lot softer than I expected
it's very tender I don't know if it's
like the oil from the pig or it's the
oil that they added on later but very
weak it's just super gelatinous like it
just feels like you're biting into fat
it's so squishy the texture and the
slime enos makes me think of snot this
is that y'all this is an oil oil doesn't
stretch like that something about it
it's just messing with my mind I just
can't get over the fact that it came
from a little thing you're eating Fred
and George and work here I think it's
important to eat other parts of the
animal otherwise it just goes to waste
it's weird that people have like certain
parts of animals that they feel are more
like justifiable to eat there's a lot
more to the animal that goes to waste I
love the idea of using the entire animal
at least that where you're kind of
respecting the whole life if you're
gonna kill an animal you might as well
utilize all of it oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
eat that what is it we open it up
oh boy